les long mur qui longe la rue lille et
geoffroy de saint pierre sang de vouloir
cacher au regard quelques mystères du
passé un passé où par endroits les
traces s'efface déjà le souvenir de
l'île et geoffroy disparaît-il avec el
kihel euphémisé geoffroy je sais que les
connais pas moi me valut moi c'était un
grand auteur de comment je suppose qu'il
écrivait huit locataires à côté ça
m'intéresse de savoir où j'habite la
langue y avait des pôles drôme ah bon ça
remonte certainement à l'histoire en
tout cas que child et plus documenté
éventuellement à sa naissance en 1755 à
saint pierre jean baptiste n'a pas
vraiment de nom il est le fils d'une a
franchi marie-geneviève ni amant et sera
adoptée par un ingénieur de la compagnie
des indes jean baptiste geoffroy
c'est d'ailleurs la première adoption de
l'histoire de bourbon comme il est né à
lille est du bassin plat il gardera
aussi ce nom enfant prodige il rentre
dès 15 ans aux ponts et chaussées en
1771 il fait partie de l'expédition
commerson au volcan de la fournaise en
souvenir de celle ci borie de
saint-vincent donnera d'ailleurs son nom
au piton l'islet jean baptiste part
ensuite à l'île de france pour
participer aux travaux de la rade de
saint louis en 1780 il y est nommé
dessinateur de génie il améliore ainsi
les cartes existantes des îles du sud
ouest de l'océan indien ile-de-france
bourbon seychelles et madagascar
le jour de ses 31 ans il reçoit une
distinction rare il est fait membre
correspondant de l'institut
un an plus tard il obtient la commission
d'ingénieurs géographe le petit rien du
tout à fait son chemin
il rentre à bourbon en 1788 et concèdent
à sa mère la propriété de l'île est à
saint pierre à la révolution se libres
de couleur fonds de la société des
sciences et des arts de lille
france puis nommé chef de la commission
du génie par des camps c'est lui qui
remettra à l'île aux anglais en décembre
1810 apprécié par les autorités il
deviendra sujets britanniques et passera
le reste de sa vie à travailler sur la
climatologie
il meurt à port louis à l'âge de 81 ans